obligatory westworld question for you
yes i know with some shows it can take a
little bit of time to kind of
get in the groove and you find that
groove in seasons one and two
and then they kind of completely shake
up the show
in season three so did you have that
period at the beginning of the season
where
you felt yourself readjusting even to a
show you knew so well
absolutely it's not like that every
season a bit season three for sure
because that was just shooting a
completely
different show um but luckily it's still
the same people
every year it's the same the same crew
that's been with us since the beginning
um and so it now we've been doing it so
long it very much is like a family
and it's still you know even though the
seasons change
it's still just as chaotic behind the
scenes and so it there's something
comforting about that
because it doesn't change um
but every season is is a reinvention and
jonah made that very clear
um from the beginning that you know
tear down the sets after every season
and start again
and and it's bittersweet because you get
to know these characters really well and
you like them how they are and then you
have to kind of start over every season
but i think it's what keeps it
interesting
that's what makes me excited for future
seasons so yeah what's season four gonna
be even i don't know